voilà monsieur bonsoir du jamais vu
depuis un quart de siècle au texas un
américain de race blanche vient d'être
condamné à mort pour crimes racistes sur
un compatriote noir une sentence rendue
sur fond de guerre entre extrémistes des
deux communautés correspondance de
philippe gassot il aura fallu attendre
trente six heures pour que les membres
du jury 11 blanc et un noir délibère et
condamne à mort john king pour le
meurtre de james byrd massacrer parce
qu'il était noir sur la foi du jury je
condamne junkie n'y à mort par injection
emmené le condamner dans le département
de la justice criminelle du texas
jusqu'au jour de l'exécution
la justice n'est pas passée par tous ses
deux complices seront jugés plus tard au
cours du procès public et jurés ont pu
jusqu'à l'écoeurement reconstituer ce
qui s'est passé le 7 juin 98 comme
pièces à conviction n'a montré la chaîne
qui a permis aux trois criminels
d'immobiliser leurs victimes et de la
traînée sur près de 5 km attaché à cette
camionnette et là le médecin légiste est
formel
james byrd était vivant et conscient
jusqu'à la fin la vidéo de la sanglante
agonie a été montrée ainsi que les
macabres reliques qui jalonnent le
chemin l'homme noir de 49 ans est mort
ici au moment où sa tête a été arraché
après avoir heurté ce tuyau john king
qui veut mourir en héros de la
suprématie blanche n'a laissé paraître
aucune émotion juste son éternel petit
sourire de repentir points même auprès
de son avocat at il exprimé des remords
il n'a aucun remords même face à la mort
il est donc un danger pour tous
on s'attend à présent à une réaction du
ku klux klan les parties de la haine
sont en nette augmentation aux états
unis et l'on craint que même dans le
couloir de la mort à huntsville john
king ne devienne un héros après tous les
recours et lui reste environ 10 ans à
vivre